so was this money from new shareholders
or existing ones
a combination but the core belief is
that this opportunity is absolutely
massive 1 billion meals are eaten on a
weekly basis in the UK dat's dinner
lunch 65 million people 70 % of meals
are home-cooked so this opportunity is
absolutely phenomenally large right now
Unilever is one of your existing
shareholders did did they participate in
this funding round they did not right
what was that strategically it's quite
important you know I have a 10-year
vision I'm absolutely convinced that
overnight success takes ten years and
and to front that vision we need a
fairly wide shareholder base okay so
what are you gonna do the money I mean
we already make your life easier better
and more natural allowing you to choose
whatever you like to eat for dinner and
then sending you the exact ingredients
you know in portions there's absolutely
no food waste and we really kind of make
your life better the new funding is
entirely used to invest into
capabilities there are four mega trends
in this market sustainability health
convenience and online and we're
benefiting from all four mega trends in
the grocery market and my humble opinion
is if you take the 10-year horizon and
you obsessively invests into
capabilities you will win a massive part
of this market how it's what you do
sustainable though because I mean a view
to service myself and it's it comes in a
huge great big cardboard box there's
lots of mucking that comes with it I
mean that don't sound terribly
sustainable you know fantastic question
to you and thank you what's really
really important is we're trading at
household level and in our supply chain
we're trading on less than 1% food waste
in the industry the average is 20
percent right so by reducing that we are
hugely sustainable now rome wasn't built
overnight now we have to tackle
packaging 88% of our packaging is
entirely recyclable which is
industry-leading and now we're working
with universities PhDs to reduce the
packaging waste further maybe even to 0%
in the next 5 years
how do
what's your point of difference with the
likes of hellofresh you're also
competing in this model sorry who what's
really really important is we are taking
the 10 year time horizon we are
obsessing about the customer
we offer by far the most choice globally
you choose from 29 years we offer by far
the most delivery options 7 days
shortest lead time morning and evening
delivery slots across all of the nation
and we're 20% cheaper were less
expensive than our closest competitor so
in every single part of the value
proposition it's a far better
proposition and what about the fact that
I mean some of the supermarkets are
moving into this I mean wait but I mean
the supermarkets are pretty well heeled
I mean they're presumably quite a threat
to you if they get their act together
are they really because over the last 50
years supermarkets have built a supply
chain that for the next 50 years is no
longer fit for purpose so 10,000
physical stores but you and I you know
going forward wanna be on the bus
picking up kids and we want to order our
food so the average order frequencies
going up dramatically average baskets
are falling
therefore the supply chain is
experiencing huge pain it is quite an
expensive service so I mean it you
really genuinely ride across the country
or is this just a bit of a London thing
80 percent of customers are outside of
London scattered across all of the UK it
costs from 298 including free delivery
across every part of the UK so it's
absolutely competitive to 98 how much
are you spending on on dinner yen well
quite but can you make money when you're
sending something worth just under three
pounds to people free of charge a great
question I have been asked that question
a few times now I mean what's really
really important is you know we obsess
about sustainability and that's
fantastic
but trading on one percent food waste
versus 20 percent it's also usually
fantastic from a business model
perspective so sustainability doesn't
you know it's there's no dichotomy it's
a false dichotomy it makes sense
win-win there's a lot of pain in the
restaurant sector right now a lot of
restaurants closing a lot of them under
room fraiche have been forced to cut
their prices do you feel that you're
contributing to that
you're taking away business from these
guys but alternately what's important is
people in the UK are cooking on a daily
basis they cooked yesterday and they
will cook tomorrow we are focused on
families young kids competitively busy
parents and they need to cook they might
go out one one day a week but we
fundamentally make their lives easier
better and you know more healthy if I
don't see restaurants as direct
competitors really but I mean you're you
are offering stuff at the high end of
the markets
potentially your your cheaper than them
in terms of price you are competitor to
them on you to some degree but again if
you look at how households are spending
money on dinner in the UK we already
fall into the 50% spending habit of
daily dinner occasions so I would argue
people could use as five to six times
and then still go out once our i-team a
bolt from gusto appreciate you joining
me could say so much Ian